how do you motivate your team I'm going
to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan so I recently got
asked a question for one of my
newsletter subscribers patrina love you
guys who wrote in to say hi Evan what's
up what's up patrina I just need advice
from you as now I started my career I'm
working Vodafone as a store manager I
sometimes feel difficult to drive my
team this is a great question for Trina
and I'm going to give you three
strategies that hopefully will help you
manage your team towards success
number one is evaluate your team members
a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of Managed
will think well how do I get these
people more excited how do I get them to
drive forward and want to hit their
goals where a lot of the time it could
just be you have the wrong people the
manager can only do so much yes you have
a big role but you have to really
evaluate if you have the right people or
not an example I'm a bluejay fan you
know if I look at the Blue Jays from
2002 to now pretty much you know if you
brought in a different manager it
wouldn't matter because the players
weren't there this year we're in a bit
of a win streak so we'll see what
happens but it wouldn't matter what
manager you brought in because the
players sucked and so you have to
evaluate your team as well and see do I
have the right people in place and if
not part of your role is to make sure
those people move on to places that they
can be successful on and you bring on
the right team to help you build a
successful business number two
understand what makes them tick people
are motivated by different things some
people are motivated by money and they
want to see how they can make a lot of
money this opportunity
some people are motivated by recognition
some people are motivated by having an
impact you need to understand for each
team member what their motivation is and
then play to it so if I'm really
motivated by money then show me how it
can make a lot of money work in a
Vodafone if I can clearly see that path
that I'm going to give you everything I
got if I'm motivated by recognition
then the money is great but I won't feel
like I'm really a part of this team and
I want to give it my all
give me some recognition tell me what a
good job I'm doing make me the Employee
of the Month have recognition programs
in place that'll make me feel more
appreciated and again likely to give up
my best if you have people who are
motivated by wanting to have an impact
what does Vodafone do to have an impact
in the community help in that first and
be a part of it how can they see how
their role in a company like Vodafone is
meaningful right so for each person you
want to understand what their motivation
is and then play to it so that they give
you their very best every day number
three is train them a lot of
entrepreneurs and and even big companies
don't do enough training you bring
somebody in and you expect them to do
really well and hit the ground running
and they often don't and you want to be
training them not just in the basics
training them you know what your
knowledge is about how to sell and how
to run your store and how to have
success but also I'd be looking at
beyond that what outside experts can you
come in to train these guys can they
potentially train each other and have
some skill sharing can you bring people
in from head office to train them and
share their experiences you want to be
an organisation that really cares about
the ongoing personal development of the
people on your team and ideally I'd love
for you and your store to be the place
that people want to go work at because
they love the training and development I
look for your your store to be the
number one Vodafone store that everybody
wants to go work at because you develop
this reputation where the training is
off the charts amazing so I'd be looking
at what is the current training that
people get offered right now it's
probably not enough for people to have a
lot of success and then how can you
oughtn't that with your knowledge with
other expert knowledge and with other
people from head office or within the
Vodafone community that can come in and
share their expertise to build your team
up so remember to evaluate the team
members understand what makes them tick
and train them believe thank you for the
great question thank you guys so much
for watching I love to know
how you train your people how you
inspire them and motivate them or how
you're planning on doing it as you bring
on your team members leave it in the
comments below I'm curious to see what
you have to say thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon